your dad was kind of a successful guy
right i mean was in the oil business
yeah yeah and your brother rooster this
i think this is another grab Lessing
roosters a self-made millionaire right
absolutely the 22 year old me and your
other brother is a millionaire as well
no he's not no but it's got to be nice
to have brothers who are successful
because you don't have to sit there and
feel guilty about your own success I
don't know if I felt guilty about it
were pretty much self reliant family and
no one really mooches off anybody in our
family and what if somebody makes it and
someone's not making it it's not
expected in our family we'll go make
sure you give money the one who's not
making did you ever jealousy because you
are famous and while those guys are
great guys they don't have the fame and
the success you have look my older
brother rooster and my mom yes maybe
mostly from my mom whose dream was to
always be on the Golden Girls right I'm
saying mom you're 85 you're out there
you still that time baby it seemed like
a wild family your mom was a
kindergarten teacher right - yeah and
and she lived to 84 she still birth day
yeah and your parents lived this lustful
life in the sense divorced twice married
three times 39 years unbelievable they
were wild and used to each other they
got rabies man and even your dad always
said I'm gonna go out probably banging
your mom he said boys when I go I'm
gonna be making love to you mother and
he did it called a shot he didn't do it
didn't he 6:30 a.m. on a Monday morning
do you believe there's something cosmic
about that you know your dad knew how he
was gonna die and he actually did it did
he have a heart attack heart
fibrillation yeah and then your mom said
I want my man to be carried out of here
nude well because I want them to see the
gift that was Jim McConaughey and all
the neighbors are out in the street he's
going out the garage down so you know
what's the sensible thing to do at 7:00
a.m. coverage right my mom's out there
half naked ripping the sheet off and get
that sheet off of him you're gonna see
how big Jim went out I hope he had a
boner at that point really she was so
proud of this man this this even though
they had been married and divorce all
this time what a [ __ ] emotional family
right she they
badasses complete outlaws yeah yeah I
guess that seems kind of like a
tight-knit family like a good deal RIT
was a great deal I mean look we we
always had this great saying in the
family hey I don't like you right now
right I love you but I don't like you
and so you never you couldn't hold a
grudge in our family either it didn't
matter what if it was a school night or
what we're gonna stay up we'll stay up
till you go to school to hash this out
but no one's going to bed with a grudge
right and it seems like your old man was
really interested in you even giving you
the discussion about the birds and the
bees oh yeah and he said to you this man
go in the shower led by [ __ ] that that
waters hid your pecker a couple of times
and and I said yeah you know when we got
that new shower had a couple years ago
that went hit me in the right spot I do
like that shower more than the other
showers